I think of authentic
assessment as my ability
to teach each student
where they actually are.
I'm Sarah Kaufman.
I teach sixth grade humanities
at School of the Future.
In order to know where they
actually are, I have to be able
to assess them really specifically
and in a variety of ways
that are appropriate
for that student,
so that what I'm doing is every day
giving that child an environment
where they're challenged, where they
feel good about what they're learning
and they feel like they're learning.
>>What's been amazing to
watch in Sarah's class
as a sixth grade teacher is also,
she just is extremely rigorous
in what she demands from the kids.
And so her class really
has high standards.
>>A lot of that work started
with myself when I would think
about reading and I would do
Post-Its while I read to figure
out what I was actually
asking the students to do.
And that led me to really break down
the skill work into smaller pieces
so that I could manage it,
because if I don't do that,
my brain can't focus.
So then, what I do is assess the
kids on skills on a continuum.
So like what we saw this
morning was I collected a bunch
of the kids' work on Friday.
I'd seen their reading labs.
I'd seen Post-Its that they'd been
making while they were reading
that were observing, inferring, you
know, visualizing and summarizing.
I took that work, I compared it
to data I had already collected
on the students by, you
know, taking a Post-It,
comparing it on this continuum.
And then I looked over the
whole class and I thought
about who needs what work where,
and then used that to make groups.
And then because I
made that continuum,
I could then pull the lessons
that each group needed,
so that eventually all
of that becomes high
level, analytical thinking.
>>We always work in groups,
whether it's working off
of writing or working off Post-Its.
Like even today, in class, you
guys saw how we were working
in Post-It groups.
It really helps, 'cause
you have someone to talk to
and they share their ideas,
or you can take off theirs,
and you can have positive
feedback and help a lot.
>>My name's Eamon McCormick.
I'm a sixth grader student
at School of the Future.
>>I started with kids that
were struggling more and
or had a more difficult
task because of it.
So that was the first
table I went to.
And at that table, I knew that they
would need more upfront instruction,
because it was a harder
skill for them.
So then I could start there, but by
the time I got to the third table,
all of those kids had
already done one Post-It.
So with the nice thing about
that was, it allowed me to first,
before I even talked to the kids,
knowing that those kids were stronger
in that work, I could then look
and see what they had done
before even speaking to them.
Giving them multiple opportunities
to practice really allowed me
while I was going round the class
to maybe change the plan as needed.
I try to structure a
lot of time that way,
so that they have a
little practice first,
and then I can assess
it as qui-- if possible.
>>It's really great to just think
about what we've been reading,
and it just lets you like
recap and not forget anything
and find the real purpose
of what's going on.
And it lets you like get the
true meaning out of the book.
>>Eamon is a really strong student.
You know, in class
today, he was talking
about how he was really
struggling to feel
like he could find depth
there in his thinking process.
And it was like, "Well, what
if we observe characters
across books and in patterns?
Like what are we seeing over
and over and over again,
and we use that as the basis
of your observation work?
What does that free up?"
So even though he's very bright
and like, you know, very capable,
he's still eleven, you know.
And like there's still things
that he need to work on.
I do as much as I can
to make him feel
like he's got something
new to try that day.
>>In eight minutes is when you're
going to have a break to talk
to a partner, to tell them, "What are
you going to write on your Post-It
that matches the work at your table?"
>>She's an amazing
sixth grade teacher,
because she really pushes the
reading, she pushes the volume
of writing and reading
her class is amazing.
I think it's made such a difference
in the tone that like has come on--
off of the kids after they leave
here to seventh and eighth.
Like it establishes that tone that
we were reader and writers in here
and continues that a lot
from elementary school,
but really takes it
to the next level.
>>I've seen a lot of success
as a teacher with kids
who are really, really struggling.
And they're so relieved that
someone finally validated the fact
that they are working really
hard and it doesn't make sense.
And then you can say, "Great,
let's work on making it less hard,
and like, here's how
we're gonna do it."
And as long as I think you
have a plan, kids feel okay.
It's when you just
sorta like, "Yeah,"
and then you don't have a plan for
them, that they really struggle.
But when you have a plan
and they go, "Oh, great,
you've thought about this.
You care about me.
You know what I need.
You're gonna help me."
And then they can just
allow themselves
to do the work that they need to do.